travis and and courtney for real just
make out non-stop that's all they do
well it is 98 of the new show chris
jenner teases what fans can expect from
her famous family's new reality show and
we're talking a whole lot of kordy
kardashian and travis barker just tune
in because you never know what's going
to happen the kardashians premieres on
hulu on april 14th and during a stop by
the ellen degeneres show tuesday the 66
year old momager said the family is
bringing it like
all of it you kind of worry about are
people still going to want to see what
we have going on because we've been
doing this for 15 years now which is a
blessing but also a little scary
and then of course the minute we start
filming a million things happen yeah
kylie's having a baby courtney's dating
travis uh barker and gets engaged and i
mean it just kept go and then kim gets
snl and i mean every single day there
was this either drama or something crazy
going on or somebody having a baby
somebody getting divorced somebody i
mean it was it was nutty as usual yeah
and according to chris fans will get to
see a lot of the 42 year old push
founder's relationship with the blink
182 drummer she jokes that all those
famous pda moments like at the grammys
the oscars and all over social media
will take up a big chunk of air time
travis and and courtney for real just
make out non-stop that's all they do
well it is 98 of the new show of course
the lovebirds got engaged on the beach
in montecito california back in october
and we know from a previous trailer that
we'll get to see all that sweetness play
out on tv one of the biggest things in
her life is about to happen and courtney
has no idea
we also know that cameras were rolling
as the couple went to the doctor's
office to start planning for a little
barker
travis and i want to have a baby
put the sample in this cup
we'll take our mics off you know get the
audio back in february a source told et
that court and trav are so in love and
are open to the idea of having children
together and growing their family i'm
just like living life and
whatever happens happens
of course courtney shares three kids
with her ex scott disick 12 year old
mason nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign while travis has
two kids of his own with his ex shayna
mookler 18 year old landon and 16 year
old alabama my children are my first
priority and you know that's one thing
that you know travis and i you know do
agree on our children come first and
their happiness and as long as you know
the kardashians are good to my kids you
know that's all that matters to me as a
mom but courtney and travis's love story
isn't the only one featured on the
famous family's new series this is a
relationship that i don't think anybody
saw coming from who are you texting ken
does his name rhyme with feet
cameras followed kim as she hosted
saturday night live back in october and
puckered up to her now boyfriend pete
davidson in this skit
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you going to kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
something very exciting came out of her
doing snl
yeah
ends with a knee um so
in the middle there's an ent last month
kim went insta official with the 28 year
old comedian at the end of the day life
is about being happy and in a recent
interview with variety the 41 year old
reality tv star said that while they
haven't filmed together yet she's not
opposed to it and kim's bff jonathan
cheban he approves i think it's cool you
know what she's having fun i guess you
know uh you know i i've hung out with
them a couple of times and
you know i love her to death so whatever
whatever makes her happy as for chris
she's just happy to have the whole crew
back together again i missed it i
realized how much i really missed it and
being with the kids every day we're
together but it's just different never
go against the family
never go against the family
[Music]
you